Brian back over to you all right Ted
thanks so many graduating from Clark
County School District over the past
week the future of course bright for
these students eight news now education
reporter Joshua peguero introduces us to
some of the Stars
when she was a kid Jessica halili
immigrated with her mother from the
Philippines not knowing any English but
dreaming of a better life she says music
helped her as I did come from a musical
background it was a lot easier for me to
grasp on to English she graduated at the
top of her class from Las Vegas high
school all while having a part-time job
on the weekends and becoming president
of the mariachi band in Las Vegas high
that required halili to learn Spanish
teachers are supposed to motivate you
and knowing with the teachers that I've
had from kindergarten until my senior
year like a lot of them have motivated
me to become the person that I am now to
continue my talents to pursue my dreams
and to continue school halili plans to
study Psychotherapy in the fall at UNLV
like khalili Daniela elves credits her
teachers for graduating from Silverado
High School with honors he really helped
me look at math in kind of like a new
way and I feel like he kind of inspired
me to like want to keep doing math
ouch says her calculus teacher Eric drum
and several others helped her attend one
of the most selective colleges in the
world Harvard a school she didn't think
she'd get into my plan was always to
like go to like UNR I think that's where
I wanted to go eligible study math at
Harvard a specialty that's
underrepresented by women for me it
never really seemed like something that
woman couldn't do because my parents
were kind of always like okay you're
going to be a doctor or you're going to
be a lawyer both ELD and halili say
without applying themselves and working
hard their dreams wouldn't be possible a
mindset they will take with them into
college Joshua figuero eight news now